blustering winds and pelting rains
didn't keep hundreds of demonstrators
from sounding off in a key free speech
case before the nation's highest court
today the justices heard a dispute over
a California law that requires most
pro-life crisis pregnancy centers to
provide information to clients about
where they can find low or no-cost
abortions several of the Centers sued
arguing their free speech rights are
infringed by being forced to support a
message antithetical to their core
mission Justice Ginsburg as the
plaintiff's lawyer why this shouldn't
equate to the idea of informed consent
quote so that the patient will know what
are the array of services available to
her but a number of justices questioned
if the laws based on making sure
potential patients are fully informed
why it's full of exceptions and
carve-outs for numerous medical
facilities and providers leaving
nonprofit pro-life pregnancy centers as
the one saddled with disclosure and
notice requirements citing a statistic
that 98.5 percent of the clinics subject
to the law are pro-life facilities
Justice Alito concluded quote when you
put all this together you get a very
suspicious pattern much of the courts
discussion centered on the laws
requirements that many pro-life
pregnancy centers would be forced to
include a lengthy disclaimer about what
services they do and don't offer often
in multiple languages in ads they run
from billboards to websites both
justices Kennedy and Sotomayor
questioned whether the disclosure
portion of the law was overly burdensome
with Kennedy going the extra step of
saying it could nullify the statute
altogether post argument both sides said
they're optimistic about winning over at
least five of the justices California
made the case that these fake women's
health centers cannot operate without
being dependent on lies and deception to
get women through their doors it's one
thing for government to ban speech
that's not acceptable but it's even
worse for the government to put words in
your mouth and turn you into their
marionette that they can force you to
say what they want you to say well two
of the justices asked today whether the
issue was even ripe to here as
California noted it's really not been
aggressively enforcing this law but
Brett whatever they decide the opinion
is do
late June okay and we'll see you tonight
at 11:00 see then thanks chef